so thank you for us very nice
instruction and just a very small
correction actually I move its mark from
genentech to Rockefeller University so
actually it's not there's a small
difference so for good morning everyone
is my great honor today to join this
symposium at the same time to share with
you some of recent research work on the
pathological integravision and as
everyone here knows as a unique
structure of neurons action form does
unique structure to transduction action
potentials and this structure is very
essential for the transaction of
neuronal signals and actually if is the
building block to form all the neural
circuits around of human bodies and the
proper functioning of this transaction
of action potentials through actions is
very important for the neuron of
pathology events such as sensing
motility cognition and memories but what
is sometimes you ignore all kind of over
soft overseeing this picture is that
some of that sounds are very long
compared to the neuronal cell bodies and
therefore is post a great challenge to
main content structure and function
integrity of axons for instance the
axons that contain or control the
movement of our food actually have their
neural cell body located in this lumber
part of the spinal cord and therefore
the axon projection of the lumber part
of spinal cord will need to be going as
long as over one meter and to reach
their tip of their food and their 04 is
not surprising that in many neuron
disease so axon actually called damaged
and lost in many titted conditions such
as Alzheimer's disease parking disease
dramatically increase Lou Gehrig's
disease multiple sclerosis collect coma
and something like that and it always
disease the damage of the axons all the
degeneration of excellence structures
actually eventually will cause the
blockage of the transaction or action
potentials or neural signals down two
exons and would erect cause to the onset
of symptoms such as policies dementia or
in the deaths of the pre human patients
for instance here is show the picture of
the spinal cord of the human patients
that's tragically died of the mattress
crosses as you can see in staining of
the axon structure by those silver
staining of the blue the black spot you
can see that is along the spinal cord
structures there's large white spot that
show the structure of axon structures
damage
so the disease conditions as you can
imagine such damage of Saxon structure
along span across structures will cause
a severe defect all the pyrolysis of the
procurement patients and here is show
another example of the traumatic injury
damage a traumatic damage of the second
nerve in human patients here's shown
that the control structure of the
sciatic nerve without any injury and you
can see there's very tightly packed in
toxins O'Malley dioxins in a unit
picture but after traumatic injury of
the trial design and nerve after a few
days or a couple of days old iphone
structure will undergo verse your help
degeneration and all the structural
damage or disappeared in a distal
portion of this second nerve and those
damage of the site in neural structures
will cause the paralyzes of the older
legs and will cause a great plan to the
patients and we're in the past few years
in my poster as we all as in my current
research at peking university working
particularly interest in the signaling
mechanism and control the pathological
acted in erosion and the reason why we
call so interesting is question is
because accumulating accumulating
evidence has suggests that pathological
generation may represent a year to be
characterized the normal test program
and the key evidence supporting this
notion is that first or research work as
well as other work in the in the in the
field suggest that this excellent test
is most of the case is not about
politics means that is not controlled by
the classical apoptotic pathways some of
a key evidence that is that in all that
began reactions in many conditions
there's no detectable activation of
caspases which is the key executor of
the pelagic pathways in those damage
actions and more importantly through the
very comprehensive genetic analysis in
your your hand will found that the
genetic depletion of a kia public
components such as specs back Cassidy's
nine caspase-3 Cosby seven casbah six do
not afford any protections of the
damaged axons amenities it conditions
therefore the axon degeneration most
likely it's not a pathetic as same time
or research also suggests that this
personal reaction generation also is non
narcotic which is a new newly identified
service program the clear evidence also
include such as the classical macro
puzzling favorite
not delay any of the degeneration in
Manatee this content at same time
duration of the kenai couple components
such as MLK ribs three have no
production at all instead of the
diseased condition with hostage taking
all these evidences together it suggests
that the pathologic axle decoration
represent a new no test program that
warranties further characterization
during my poster research as markets 11
slide by rock of university with a very
has to approve a whole genome screen
impact shra we first identify key
regulator of the pathologic x-axis
generation which would cause someone as
a RM one as you can see here is show the
control condition which in the white
have mice will do the site in neural
injury after a couple of days old act on
the structure will generate in the
distal portion of the sciatica nerve and
as st. hi all the axonal terminal which
innervates hinder limb muscles for
example the tibialis anterior muscles
with disappear as shown by the green
staining of the terminal of axons while
the rest then in showed the structure of
the acetylcholine receptors on the
muscle in sharp contrast in the semi
knockout after the same send in your
injuries all the actions could return
their structure integrity as long as two
here shows six days as positive longest
one we have done is three weeks
basically as long as two three weeks the
summer knockout can maintain this XML
structure after the physical injuries
moreover even in for the terminal
structure of the axonal projections into
to can show the matter movement you can
see the structure of the motor neuron
axons could remain intact as long as 26
days after the traumatic injuries this
is the first evidence of the loss of
function study showing that the
pathologic acceleration is actually
controlled by genetically defined
pathway with the seventh being a central
regulator of this program and then to
answer the question as to how the sermon
transduce the degeneration signal to the
downstream event we continue screening
for the isochoric library and then we
are able to identify a classical map
kinase pathways composed of the three
Maps 3k type compressor composed of
three Maps 3k connie's too much cake and
knees and stream app cake honey's that
function as the central
Tom streaming event or signal
transduction modules that ran stream of
someone and here showed example of the
option or injury as G in the control
condition in the that's the first column
you can see that after this the
traumatic injury of the optic nerve
after a few days although a tax on in
the damage of general was the general
hit a complete fragmented but in the
short concert again when we knock down
or knock all together with the junk one
comes to junk three all the street maps
3-kinase here all the axons could return
in track as long as 26 days after
injuries this suggests that some lamb is
likely to functions to risk map kinase
pathways let's regulate the degenerative
process and then we try to attract of
the question as to how this term one map
kinase pathways could transduce the
signal further downstream to cause the
fragmentation of arsenal's to this end
we observe a very interesting phenotype
that we're going to elaborate on in
first talk is that it appears that the
pathologic acceleration seem to have
close connection with the metabolic
status of the axons after the injury to
it it means that we were able to
directly measure the axonal ATP levels
after the different hand point of the
universe as you can see in his blue
lines after different tempo and after
injury there is a very dramatic job of
ATP levels very quickly job of traumatic
a very quickly job of ATP levels in the
damaged axons and it's pierced by this
Western blot correlating with its ATP
job that when the ATP level reached the
final stage which is basically and
detectable level that's a generally
completely with the conflict cleavage of
of the maximum structural proteins and
then choose the probe that it is ATP
depletion is the causative event of an
accent generation we play some trick
that we were able to return or mentions
the akp level in damage actions by
providing the axons with some metabolic
inter mediums for example here is show
the derivative of mindful pyruvate is
above our weight which is a derivative
of a key the product of the tittle
glycolysis and it is also very important
fuel to fit into the TCA cycle as you
can see we were able to trace actions
with this methyl pyruvate as shown in
these red lines they can complete it's a
verse it's were significantly delay the
drop of ATP levels after the damage not
only soul is
delay of ATP job correlate with almost a
complete protection of axonal structures
after the damage of the axons this
suggests that is the HP depletion is a
causative event after the damage of the
exams Maury we were able to show that
its energy depletion or energy defeated
it's actually function downstream of the
someone map kinase pathways because when
we do the Wi-Fi control we can see this
ATP depletion happens as I show just in
the past lies having a very quickly
after the damage but in contrast in the
storm one knockout oh when we knock out
or knocked down the jump to junk retreat
or junk when together there is also a
very dramatic delay of this ATP
depletion suggesting that very likely is
summer map kinase pathway function to
control this local only this local
energy this local energy defeated event
then calls the downstream event called
the dead degeneration of exams then as
the final stage of how the connection of
ATP depletion is we political whole ATP
depletion is connected with the physical
fragmentation of axons we have very
convincing evidence suggests just for
sake of time I'm not going to show you
most of them is that after the ATP
depletion there's accumulating of
causing instead of axons which is not
surprising because as I will know here
the memory potential of the axons or
neurons a whole is need consistent input
of 88 EP to be maintained and with ATP
depletion 0 for this lot of the
maintenance of this imbalance across
members will cause accumulating on
calcium instead of axons and this
accumulation of calcium instead of axons
will eventually cause activation of a
classical causing active produce called
Calvin's and this calvin activation will
cause the final fragmentation of axons
to support this idea with first use a
genetical approach to delete the cause
editor to delete the current activities
through this calvin for conditional cult
as you can see it is often or interest
models in the control condition after a
few days of often their injuries all the
axons degenerate and fragmented in sharp
contrast again which is called a calvin
depletion or inhibition of a calvin
signal there is almost a complete
protection of the external structure up
to even to six days after injuries
moreover we were able to show that this
carbon indeed function downstream of ATP
because we're a very simple trick we are
able to use the colony inhibitors that
in comilla carbon activities and
strongly protect your actions posting
via individual but this carbon
inhibitors have no effect at all to
delayed ATP depletion inside of axons as
shown this right length compared to the
control blue lines supporting our
hypothesis this character activation is
functioning downstream of a TPS and
therefore in my previous post our
research in dr. McCrae eleven's lab we
were able to deal in your eyes an oval
signaling pathways starting from the Sun
1 to 10 stream map kinase pathways to
further downstream an ATP depletion
event and leading to the fund activation
of confidence that cost of fragmentation
and the degeneration axons and when I
move on to my next job and my working in
University last year's strength to
answer one of the key questions in this
product in this diagram is that how the
local energy homeostasis got distracted
in time' Jackson's basically what is the
cause the event for its ATP depletion
after the damage and to this line we
were able to first to refresh your mind
hopefully you still remember about 11
that is the energy homeostasis in the
mammalian cells in essays melissa is not
implant in mammalian cells is mainly
supported or a solid support by the two
major pathways that can generate ATP the
first one is coca-cola kahless's let's
use the degradation or partial
metabolize of a glucose which generate a
porter of ATP and and the product of the
calculus is pyruvate was then feed into
the TCA cycle and through a TCA cycle
and the electron transport agent chain
which I name is a large amount of a GPS
and because we already know in time
which axons there is the ATP depletion
oal energy d visit with your for try to
understand which portion of this energy
homeostasis got disrupted what is
correct Hollis's or whether it's the TCA
cycle and for the sake of time I'm going
to show some of very brief results and
we were able to use a very very smooth
week with a very fast effective trick
then can analyze the event holy going on
in the axons but by surgically remove
the neuronal cell bodies for zulemita
cultures but
so we were able to focus solely
biochemically on the event of the 8th
energy status in the exams after
injuries and by doing so we first looked
ask question whether the uptake of
glucose for exam may be affected after
injury and the answer is no because we
can use a very classical radio labeled
glucose uptake I say through the
supporting label to crackle
2-deoxyglucose as you can see after
injury of the axons there's no
significant effect of a glucose uptake
in the exams and for sick time I'm not
going to show you we all were also able
to analyze the TCA cycle efficiency in
the interactions and answer is still no
is that there's no clear defect of the
TCA cycle in the interactions are in the
up to the time point with ATP depletion
already occurs therefore we put off for
Cassandra Clare Colossus and to do the
correct cause analysis we use a very
classical and very old trick is that we
can reconstitute the clock electrolysis
event in the test tube to do that we can
isolate the axonal proteins cells all
recording of axons oh all the cells or
component of axons and then we could
provide this mixture of cytosol control
set us all the components of the axons
with intermedia michalak policies which
is the fructose 1 6 by phosphate but
doing so we can reconstitute the
production of ATP completely individual
as you can see with the control
condition there is no a hippie
generation at all as is showing the blue
line but when we provide this in visual
reconsidering system with food co 2 16
by phosphate there's very rapid and very
efficient generation of ATP in visual
and then we will use this IC to acid the
axonal structure sorry the axonal
contents isolated from different kind
point after the injury which is a third
time point or the fourth after injury as
you can see in the right line compared
to the blue line so at sonic content
isolate after the injury for our after
injuries shows to giving a defect in the
production of ATP is through the correct
Hollis's event this is the first
indication that is there see me to be a
blockage or the empowerment of the
glycolytic a TV production in the
interactions for the question is why and
before going through the question why's
that why this happens we first asked a
question is whether this closet EP fact
it's also trans from the summer map
kinase pathways and choose which shows
that most of little here is that we
found that this blockage of the calculus
ii a TV production is actually depend on
the side my map kinase signal because as
I just showing past lies in the white
hat in the white have axons with if we
do this caracalla this image is a so
called ATP production drop very rapidly
after injury or in contrast when you
have the storm and knock all exons going
into this I say the main turn almost
completely men turn their ability to for
this color quality a TV production up to
even though stick hours after injury
which already there's always signal
delay there are six signal decrease in a
white hype axons and then with that
we're trying to explore the reason why
there's a blockage or empowerment of a
clock holiday ATP production in the in
axons and just to make a story short we
found that actually there is a very
central co-factors that is essential for
the calculus is going through from the
fructose 1 6 by 4 straight to the heat
production which is an ID as this and Ed
is a essential factor to disturb
catalyzed by the Kappa th all the
classroom although highest 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase and we use the very
classical of very efficient way to might
add ATP level in the exams to the radio
labeling of the atb through its ruler
read it with your labeling of an ad
precursor equal to in the night as you
can see after injury when we measure the
a 1080 content in the introductions
there's also very rapid drop of energy
level instead of excess most notably is
that this NDT job in fact of axons is
actually in parallel with ATP job
instead of axons this indication that is
only the job or an ad depletion in
happens inside our actions may be
related or physically hornell physically
connected with a 2 ATP depletion inside
our exams to Travis hypothesis we play
very simple trick we can add the eggs
ordinance a 1080 in torreón virtual call
ecology Isis to see whether this
extraordinary nad could rescue local
ecology a TV production in virtual in
directions as you can see here the white
bar as I just showed him past two slides
after injury there's a dramatic decrease
or signal decrease of the analytic
productions or glycolysis instead of
actions but if it provides a exotic
level the source of 180 into this I say
the only depress the ATP production so
we collect hostile reaction could almost
be completed rescued it suggests that
the depletion of axonal led is actually
cold here to this blockage of glycolytic
ATP production but then the question
next question is why than I ducati
plated and to refresh a man again of the
basic biology of the energy metabolism
in the mammalian cells the ID is mainly
synthesized through a recycling pathway
is to the precursor of nicotinamide and
the nicotine matter will be condensed
the ways ATP first to choose generates
an intermedium called nicotinamide and
one on occupied as a nicotine NY one
look at heart will be further condensed
with LED as I with ATP to turn in the
final product of a lady at is nad in
certain in certain conditions will be
brick down or consumed through certain
class of energy consumption enzymes I
will talk about later that will break
landlady back into the precursor
nicotinamide and if that's the case then
we ask question why don't make each off
instead of axons after injuries to do
that with took advantage of the IC of
our energy level because we use the
radio label nicotine demise as a
precursor to label the lady therefore it
enabled us to do a post chaise I say to
determine the fate or the half-life of
energy after injuries as you can see the
experience that happens like that is
likely this we first the label axons for
three days with radio labeled
nicotinamide just before the external
injuries with a wash away that we don't
label nicotinamide but then trace the
axons with unlabeled dynamite party and
so were actually measuring the half-life
of nicotine mud in the axons comparator
injured and uninjured conditions as you
can see in the blue lines in I injured
conditions the nith is actually very
very stable in federal actions with our
half-life longer than 24 hours as lot as
far as we can go here is actually small
here but in sharp contrast abstracts on
the injuries there's a dramatic increase
as the selector
magic decrease of the half-life of on 18
set of axons where's a half left on ad
shift to about three hours with the
attack on injuries this suggesting that
actually the array of axonal injury in
particular active the consumption of an
ID a actual process of consumption of an
ad in the axles and to further support
this hypothesis we can measure the fate
of the radio labeled nad after injury
similarly use or purchase I say as you
can see after the injury we can measure
the level of the older nad precursor
together with the mini medium instead of
the whole quarter system as you can see
here here is a black bar shows an ad
level inside of axons while the white
bar shows a Latino male level instead of
axons you can see after injury well
there's a rapid job of total energy
level as show that black bars there
actually a corresponding increase of
nicotinamide interactions suggesting of
further suggesting that is after to
axonal injuries so honey tea called
active consume and turning back into its
precursor in Cuttino mad and with other
information with the makeup workers on
to advance all the huben that a catalyst
is brick down or the consumption of
young lady to his precursor nicotinamide
basically while focusing on ad consuming
and dance there are two major family of
immediate sorry peep before i go into
that we also were able to show that this
active consumption of nad similar to the
LED depletion event is functioning
downstream of summer map kinase pathways
because when we do the energy
measurement old ID half-life measurement
you can see in the control conditions
the energy half-life always going to
about three hours after injury well in a
seminar called the to map 2k magnum
knock out all the dreamers came now
college entrance exam three you can see
the half life of an ID call signaling
increased bring to about eight hours
something like that after injuries
suggesting this Activision consumption
of nad is indeed functioning downstream
of samurai map kinase pathways and then
as I just said we make off workers to
identify the event or the molecules or
proteins that cause the consumption of
nad inside of axons to do that we took a
very simple but a little bit tedious
approach we call all the antibodies we
can purchase
through the in the community required
from request from the community
recognize all the American same enzymes
that is two families the first family is
a search engine family the next family
is the power family through is very
simple but some little bit tedious
approach we were able at n t5 that is
first all the seven members of a certain
family members have expressed in the
neurons but some of them showed
different localization for example the
third one which is already expressed and
that Holden neurons but when we
fashioned a neurons will use the orb /
trick to isolate those axons from the
neuron cell bodies you can see so
certain one actually is exclusively
localized in the neuronal cell bodies
but now in that sense and similarly we
will do the same thing first 36 is also
the third six I clue is exclusively
localizing it cell phone late but not
accidents I but as in hand you can see
our approach in immediately many of the
search engine family members and many of
the power family members I indeed exist
Oh indeed present in the axonal fraction
which flow in the axonal fractions for
example sister to the pub six and
purpose 11 on something like that with
that information within try to identify
or explore the possibility that one or
more of his family members of nad
consumer lenses may participate in
energy consumption after injury in the
axons to that I with performer as HR
screening all kinda detection screening
to identify the search of her family
members that may delay that none of them
may delay technol generation after the
injury and we were lucky that is we were
able to identify two family members the
third 532 and pop3 that when knock down
each of them they actually called
partial deletion they cause a partial T
delay of economic generation compared to
the control conditions but they seem to
function these two proteins seem to
function additively because when we
knock down both of them together the
further enhance the protection of the
external the further delay the
degeneration of axons after injuries
it's gave the first indication that 32
and pop3 are the two major energy
consuming enzymes that may involve on
I involved in accent evaluation after
the injury and supporting the idea that
it is 30 to pursue it I indeed a
required for active energy consumption
after injury as well as for appt patient
after injuries which causes 30 pubs
three knockout mice and a same as on top
of that we use the Shi to deplete the 32
as you can see well it matters a lady
half life in interactions compared to
the control condition there's also a
similar shift or the increased signaling
increase of the half life of an ID
instead of excellence after injury when
he played lead to an ad consumer lenses
and correspondingly we depleted to any
consumer intense there's a corresponding
increase all checked there's
corresponding a delay of the ATP
depletion instead of exons compared to
the control conditions suggesting this
qu nad consumers as maybe did inquire a
required for the this metabolic events
going on in the damaged actions and then
finally we're going to the in vivo I say
to the mouse model to determine whether
is qu nad consumer enzyme may indeed
regulates as a pathological degeneration
of the axons in Babel and we just got
some polymer results showing tons of
ideas here we first use the fluorescence
immune of hybridization sorry
fluorescence in situ to identify the
expression profile of the 32 and pop3
here short example of the congress as
the sympathetic ganglia as you can see
by the fluorescence in situ together
with the cost any of the track a marker
for the neuronal cells you can see
there's a perfect hole colocalization of
the expression of surgery two and part
three which track a labeled axon and
neurons suggests that indeed express in
the neurons at least the in a simple
cycle ganglia and then you know in vo I
say for the degeneration of Texans after
injury we use a model that we can
determine the degeneration of the
synthetic stones after the fatal
injuries to that I we can hear is show
the diagram of the model system as in
the mouse brain there is a circle
superior cervical Congress which is a
sympathetic ganglia that have their
axons one of the branch of the axons
projecting into the brain which control
the contraction of the blood vessels
that providing the floor blood flow into
the brain
and if this production is important to
control the blood flow and to make sure
the blood flow matched the requirement
or demand for energy inside of bring we
can surgically remove the cell body
localized in this superior cervical
Congress by doing so cheering the axons
from the neural cell bodies and then ask
what the fate of those axons of his
damage as you can see his control
condition when we analyze this original
of the blood vessels which have all that
much habitants of mash of axonal
sympathetic axons in shedding the blood
vessels after injury although almost all
the sympathetic axons or degenerate into
days but in contrast or inversion of
contrast in the 32 substrate
double-column eyes the general process
is largely delayed its provide the first
piece of evidence in vivo that the 32
perhaps three indeed participated in the
deterioration of axons at least for the
symbolic actions available so taking all
the star together to get today I'm
showing to you that is in the first
proteomics research in the practice in
traumatic events life we were able to
determinant OT limit delineate a
signaling pathways that is no wall for
the degeneration of axons after
pathological insult and in my ongoing
research while trying to make a
connection of a multipolar connection
between the degeneration event together
with Lady consumption instead of axons
and the for sake of time not going to
tell you is that we also have evidence
suggesting the energy production or only
distance Isis is also a key with insider
actions because depletion of aqui na
dekhe synthetic enzyme which color mini
2 in axons can cause a spontaneous
generation of axons without any damage
suggesting further suggesting that led
is essential for survival axons under
the normal physical conditions fidalgo
conditions and with that I would like to
first thank you my mentor a post on
mentor dr. McChrystal alone for his
support of my poster research at the
Rockefellers actually at a rockefeller
university and my ongoing research at
the university is supported by the
school of life sciences the joint center
of life sciences the igg Micawber
Institute as well as well as the
National Science Foundation
and but most of all I always would feel
privileged to work with some of my very
talented graduate student which have
been forming the core and the foundation
of my research group so thank you for
attention
[Applause]